Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu die neunundzwanzigste ausgabe mein name ist tim und heute am.
Achten juni zwanzig zwanzig die sonne scheint und wir kommen mal wieder zusammen wir haben unser weekly nicht ganz geschafft.
Letzte woche haben wir beschlossen nochmal etwas zeit vergehen zu lassen um.
Nochmal genauer ein blick auf so ein paar offene fragen werfen zu können ich sage erstmal hallo pavel.
Ja hast du die zeit gut nutzen können.
Naja ich hab gehört tatsächlich mein bisschen mal jetzt einen erholungswert wochenende eingelegt,
hör auch und bin nicht ganz so schnell vorwärts gekommen wie ich wollte aber
es passiert gerade auch nicht so furchtbar viel an der corona front muss man auch sagen immer ein bisschen themen haben wir jetzt schon zusammen und ich
habe halt vor allen dingen in sagen die ganze basis wie ich jetzt die daten auf arbeite und
erfasse und zähle nochmal komplett.
Überarbeitet und da fehlt allerdings jetzt noch das dazu passende frontend da bin ich dran ich hoffe dass ich damit dann diese woche dass es dann ab,
geben wird mit auch so features dass man dann konkret für jeden landkreis und bundesland dann auch zurückschauen
kann so die sich die fälle der letzten zwei monate anschauen kann wie es da ausgesehen hat wann da was reingekommen,
ist und wie sich das so entwickelt hat so dass hilft glaube ich dann auch nochmal besser zu verstehen wenn man so einen landkreis sich sich anschaut und,
ja und außerdem habe ich dann nochmal einiges an zeit drauf geschmissen mal mehr hamburg genauer anzugucken weil es da halt doch fragen gab,
weil,
jemand dann auch eine anfrage beim gesundheitsamt dort in hamburg gestellt hat was ist denn aber ich los und da kam dann als antwort nur alles in ordnung es gibt bei uns gar keine verspätung wir melden
ohne verzögerung was halt kann man jetzt schon vorwegnehmen so nicht ganz
also zumindest passt diese aussage nicht ganz mit den daten zusammen die das veröffentlicht.
Schauen wir uns gleich nochmal genauer an ansonsten kann man feststellen es gibt ja international gute und schlechte nachrichten
so insgesamt gibt's so sieben millionen gezielte infizierte weltweit ein voran natürlich immer noch die usa aber
vor allem wenn man sich so brasilien anschaut da geht's irgendwie immer noch erst so richtig los hat man so den eindruck
russland auch nicht so sehr viel besser alles auch so länder die etwas schwierig sind zu bewerten weil einerseits man nicht genau weiß ob du überhaupt ausreichend getestet und gedruckt wird und brasilien wurde jetzt sogar
bekannt gegeben man würde jetzt einfach überhaupt gar keine zahlen mehr veröffentlichen weil sie dem präsidenten nicht so richtig in kram passen ob das so eine strategie ist die erfolgversprechender ist da bin ich mir noch nicht so ganz so sicher.
Und es gibt natürlich noch so ein paar schlafende riesen wo man noch gar nicht so richtig weiß was auf einen zukommt indien ist da zum beispiel zu nennen die immer noch ja relativ exponentiell ansteigende zahlen haben,
hallo
während man in europa langsam aber sicher die geschichte im griff zu bekommen scheint.
Vielleicht mit der ausnahme von wo wo es zwar auch eine leichte abflachung gibt aber naja die zahlen sind noch relativ hoch sehr viele todes zahlen und denke was in den nächsten wochen auch noch.
Häufiger zu hören sein wird sind eben die vergleiche der todesfälle insgesamt im vergleich zu den vorjahren.
Und da gibt es noch nicht so richtig breite berichterstattung aber das was so durchsickerte ist dass das alles noch ganz ordentlich nach oben
korrigiert werden muss.
Und tatsächlich sind die todeszone viel ist eigentlich fast das einzige was man
in den ländern untereinander vergleichen kann weil es zeichnet sich halt immer mehr ab dass die testphase also die.
Zahl der infizierten doch stärker abhängt von der menge der tests die gemacht wird als von allem anderen.
Ja gut natürlich können die tests nichts melden wo nichts los ist aber
so ansonsten man hatten wir auch schon vor
einigen wochen sogar auch dieses paper was jemand sehr schön dazu geschrieben hat wie denn das ausweiten oder reduzieren von tests sich auf die infizierten kurve auswirkt und das
bewahrheitet sich halt jetzt,
alles so dass man eigentlich die zahlen für ein land ohne die entwicklung der tests zu sehen nicht wirklich einschätzen kann was da los ist.
Und dann selbst wenn man die tests zahlen dann hat ist dann immer noch die frage wer wird,
wie getestet was ist das konkrete tests regime das dort gefahren wird
und dementsprechend können die tatsächlichen zahlen ich sage mal im besten fall bei ländern wie deutschland wo,
wer nur eine dunkelziffer quote von.
Um die sechs haben kann es in anderen ländern sein dass es das doppelte bis dreifache ist ungefähr so das heißt das sind so
die variation mit denen man rechnen muss wenn man länder miteinander vergleicht also wenn,
irgendein land weniger als dreimal so hoch ist wie ein anderes land so dann kann das tatsächlich sein dass sie eigentlich identisch
sind die tatsächlichen infizierten zahlen wenn man
dann jetzt nur nach den tests geht besser vergleichbar sind halt tatsächlich die sterbe zahlen wobei da natürlich auch die,
frage ist wie die gezählt werden das heißt am ende wissen wir es dann erst wie du schon richtig gesagt hast wenn dann eben die
den normalen sterben statistiken plötzlich man eine überstaatlichen zeit,
findet dann ist das sehr wahrscheinlich dass man,
das dann am ende vergleichen kann gab es eine oder gab es keine und bei uns.
War in deutschland bisher nur eine ganz leichte delle sichtbar somit mal ja größenordnungsmäßigen zwei dreihundert mehr fälle pro tag.
Für einen zeitraum als wir auf dem höhepunkt waren
mittlerweile hat sich das halt auch komplett normalisiert und das wo in deutschland täglich zwischen normalerweise zwei bis dreitausend menschen sterben aus den unterschiedlichsten gründen war aber durchaus sichtbar dass,
eigentlich dann im april wo üblicherweise die zahlen,
grippe und ähnliches meistens runtergehen wenn man sich die vorjahre anguckt war da plötzlich einen anstieg.
Man muss natürlich auch dann abwarten bis das so ein bisschen mal gegen gerechnet wird ich denke zum beispiel an sowas wie verkehrstote.
Ja
Da kann es nämlich durchaus sein dass eben durch weniger verkehr und dann einfach auch da geringere zahlen aufgetreten sind das muss man natürlich dann auch noch gegen rechnen.
Ja aber das ist so jetzt überschlägig sagen haben wir verkehrstote in dem
in der größenordnung ich glaube von zwei bis dreitausend jahr insgesamt und das heißt es sind so
ja weiß nicht zehn am tag das heißt es wird jetzt selbst wenn es gar keine mehr gäbe wird das jetzt für den,
zeitraum auch für für jetzt wird es nicht so den großen unterschied machen ich meine wo halt
wer immer noch ja in der größenordnung also genauso viele korona tote immer noch haben wie verkehrstote im moment das wo wir schon jetzt ziemlich weit wieder oder relativ weit unten sind.
Ja während also international die zahl aber noch steigt
der gemeldeten infizierten gibt zumindest einen kleinen lichtblick wenig überraschend hat neuseeland jetzt bekannt gegeben dass sie überhaupt gar keine fälle mehr haben also die letzte person die da noch in beobachtung war
ist dann über den abwartet zeitrum hinaus,
jetzt auch beobachtet worden und die berichten gerade mal zweiundzwanzig tote insgesamt.
Und wir haben einfach gar keine fälle mehr das ist gut sind fünf millionen einwohner nicht so viel,
trotzdem das spricht halt sehr dafür dass es relativ gut im griff bekommen haben und sie haben ja auch die strategie des harten lok downs verfolgt da sie haben halt einfach komplett zugemacht für
jetzt nicht ganz genau welchen zeitraum also insgesamt war die phase so fünfundsiebzig tage lang und haben dann glaube ich irgendwie ein zwei monate so richtig alles runtergefahren.
Natürlich werden die auch unter den wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen zu leiden haben denkt da vor allem man tourismus etcetera aber keine ahnung unterm strich werden sie dann doch.
Noch eher gut davon gekommen sein ist natürlich jetzt für eine insel einfacher aber das ist auch auf einer insel schiefgehen kann das sieht man halt in,
großbritannien.
Bei großbritannien fällt mir ein hast du irgendwie boris johnson letzten auftritt mitbekommen wo er doch doch darum geworben hat.
Doch die ganzen arbeiter aus der eu jetzt bitte wieder zurückkommen mögen und bitte wieder die arbeit auf dem gut wir müssen uns zwar erstmal für vierzehn tage in quarantäne aber ansonsten.
Super statement ja das.
Kommt bitte wieder ja.
Und er klang auch nicht so super fit muss man sagen als er das sagte sie frage war jetzt einfach nur unterzuckert oder leidet er doch noch irgendwie an corona spätfolgen weil das war.
Doch alles etwas in kohärent was er gesagt.
Na ja aber er redet generell sehr in kohärent von daher fand ich das jetzt nicht sonderlich auffällig also ist meine immer schon jemand der einfach so daher redet und irgendwie nicht so den eindruck gemacht als er dann klaren plan.
Aber das war schon wirklich mit extrem viel und und also mit nicht artikulierte worten dazwischen also mehr mehr als ich zu besten zeiten zustande.
Die briten bezeichnet das bei ihm als bowling also dieses dahin gerede von von irgendwelchen worten das ist das ist bei ihm eigentlich auch normal.
Okay.
Ich höre mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so oft bis gar nicht an weil das bereitet mir dann oft tatsächlich fast körperliche schmerzen es ist selber wie mit trump ähm.
Ja ja das kann ich auch nicht ertragen auf dauer.
Ist wirklich schmerzhaft so.
Gut dann hatten wir letztes mal um ein bisschen feedback gebeten was du diese ganze antikörper test geschichte betrifft da kam auch einiges zurück.
Aber auch ganz interessant also erstmal haben wir noch so gerätselt wie ist denn das jetzt eigentlich mit der verfügbarkeit stellt sich raus
ja verfügbarkeit ist eigentlich gar kein problem wer also ein antikörper test auf
neunzehn fette machen will kann dies tun da braucht man in der regel nur zum hausarzt zu gehen.
Weiß nicht ob das generell für alle hausärzte gilt aber es muss ja eigentlich nur blut abgenommen werden das dann zu einem labor eingesendet wird.
Ich hatte allerdings jetzt sehr sehr sehr unterschiedliche rückmeldungen bekommen zu wie lange dauert das.
Und was kostet das also da habe ich auch irgendwie alles gelesen von jahrzehnten euro und ein tag später war das ergebnis da bis hundert euro und hat zehn tage gedauert also.
Und alles dazwischen.
Und genau und alles dazwischen also es war jetzt nicht nur entweder oder ich habe es mir kurz aufgeschrieben ich habe zehn euro zweiundzwanzig dreißig sechzig siebzig und hundert euro habe ich jetzt gelesen,
das mag wohl ein wenig davon abhängen bei welchem labor das gemacht wird ansonsten kann ich das nicht so richtig beurteilen.
Wer da jetzt sich an welcher stelle noch ein scheibchen aus dem kuchen herausnimmt so groß ist der kuchen ja nicht.
Aussagekraft ist umstritten also wurde darauf hingewiesen es gibt verschiedene test ich kann jetzt gerade nicht so aufzählen dieser.
Blutabnahme test also ein begriff ist auf jeden fall dieser leiser antikörper test.
Ja keine ahnung also ich habe da noch so einen link bekommen virus dog de da kann man seine postleitzahl eingeben und dann kriegt man irgendwie auch noch.
Liste von.
Praxen oder test stellen wo dann entsprechende isolierung smash nahmen getroffen werden ob die jetzt noch so erforderlich sind ist eine andere frage ja und.
Ich habe jetzt keinen gemacht.
Ne wir hatten eigentlich hatten wir versprochen oder angekündigt wir würden irgendwie beide ein.
Machen aber ja das war dann plötzlich dann doch alles nicht so aufregend,
und ja man kann also die labore bieten es halt einfach an so wie alle möglichen anderen,
tests die man machen lassen kann so bluttests so,
ja wenn sofern tatsächlich hausarzt und dann gibt's aber noch informationen des die jetzt erstattungsfähig tatsächlich sogar sein sollen die antikörper tests,
ansonsten zahlen sehen es gibt halt drei verschiedene antikörper oder immun globulis die da.
Potenziell getestet werden können und je nachdem welche da genommen werden kannst da dann wohl
auch zu falschen positiven durch andere corona viren geben aber üblicherweise scheint aber der,
corona virus ist voll das was dann auf dem anforderungen schein zu stehen hat,
also es war so der
antikörper test ist wohl derjenige der am spezifischen ist und ideal und igmg nachweise sinnvoll problematisch,
aber idealerweise würde man gerne alle sehen
weil man dann doch noch ein bisschen mehr daraus ablesen kann aber standard scheint so zu sein dass halt ein antikörper test gemacht wird wenn man
zum hausarzt geht wenn man's um corona geht.
Mir ist noch eine studie zugespielt worden die auch so als brief draußen ist wo leute untersucht wurden die kurve neunzehn.
Hatten sie nicht komplett durchgelesen ich kann medizinischen paypal häufig gesagt nicht so richtig verstehen sie so lese mir einfach eine eine sprache die ich nur sehr schwer.
Dekodiert bekomme die mal geschaut hat was haben denn die leute eigentlich für eine für ein bluttest.
Wie sagt man blut typ.
Blutgruppe.
Blutgruppe genau was haben die finde für eine blutgruppe und da war es dann wohl so dass irgendwie.
Die blutgruppe ab positiv also aplaus eine höhere das risiko hatte und dass man irgendwie bei der gruppe null er.
Ein protective effekt festgestellt habe also das
wie gesagt ein paper prima print und so weiter kann alles auch komplett falsch sein aber das wird auch nochmal ganz interessant sein zu sehen ob sich auf der ebenen und einer form noch etwas ergibt.
Ja
also mich würde das zumindest nicht wundern wenn dem so wäre weil ja auch schon länger bekannt ist dass das virus ja nicht nur die lunge angreift sondern.
Auch alle möglichen organe und das tatsächlich auch das blut.
Insbesondere auch glaube ich die roten blutkörperchen eine bestimmte rolle dabei spielen weshalb man,
auch dann auf das queen gekommen ist überhaupt oder der vermutete effekt beim hydroxysäure beruhte jetzt nicht darauf,
dass das jetzt das virus abgetötet sondern dass es dann deine blutzellen schützt vor dem virus was nach stand der studien
aber nicht so zu sein scheint es zumindest die sterblichkeit nicht niedriger ist sondern eher höher wenn es gegeben,
wird so also man sofern konnte man bisher noch keine vorteile sehen obwohl halt erstaunlicherweise ganz viele ärzte.
Darauf zu schwören scheinen oder zu schwören schienen aber ja das ist natürlich nicht so richtig wissenschaftlich.
Ja da wollen wir uns jetzt auch gar nicht in die bewertungsemail gegeben da haben wir einfach nicht die notwendige grundbildung geschweige denn richtige ausbildung
dafür gab auch noch so einen anderen artikel dass irgendwelche ärztin italien beobachtet haben wollen dass so insgesamt bei den leuten die sie jetzt positiv testen
im mittel die viruslast zurückgeht.
Mit der vermutung ob denn das nicht vielleicht bedeuten könnte dass hier der virus soweit mutiert ist oder andere effekte mit reinspielen das im die aggressivität zurückgeht.
Muss man auch beobachten.
Das thema hatten wir glaube ich auch schon das ist zumindest also auch das wäre plausibel,
durch durchaus weil natürlich wenn getestet wird und wenn insbesondere leute in quarantäne,
gesteckt werden die symptome zeigen dann gibt es natürlich einen gewissen evolutionären druck auf das virus sich einfach zu verstecken und weniger symptome zu machen so aber gleichzeitig ist
eben auch so dass halt grundsätzlich eben mutationen in der regel nicht positiv,
so klingt ja immer so hoch das virus mutiert und wird jetzt gefährlich und böse in der regel ist es genau das umgekehrte so der der fall normalerweise ist motivation des virus halt nicht besser machen.
Also nicht besser also für für den menschen schon besser aber halt nicht für für die negativen auswirkungen ja.
Sicht ist genau aus sicht des virus jetzt sozusagen nicht unbedingt jetzt in dem sinne.
Aus sicht des virus geht's ja virus will ich ja gar nicht töten das virus will ja nur weitergereicht werden und von daher ist das eben dann eben die strategie so okay ich war zu laut sondern dann muss ich mich halt mehr zurückhaltend wenn ich hier überhaupt noch weitergereicht werden möchte.
Ja das ist das ist eine sache aber das andere ist eben auch dass die meisten mutationen einfach dazu führen dass das virus selber ich sage mal krank wird oder schwach wird weil es einfach nicht
die meisten mutationen schädigen eigentlich des virus.
Ja
In seiner potenz wie auch immer also in seiner möglichkeit jetzt zählen zu infizieren und sich zu vervielfältigen und so und die vielleicht,
ganz wenigen seltenen positiven gehen dann eher sogar in richtung das ist halt für uns harmloser wird aber.
Ja also insofern würde das auch würde das auch durchaus passen so wo wir speziell das korona virus relativ also vergleichsweise noch stabil sein soll weil es irgendwie noch mal kontrolliert,
wenn es sich vervielfältigt man hat es noch ein paar reparaturmechanismen die so mutationen wohl unterdrücken aber ja,
das funktioniert natürlich auch nicht alles hundertprozentig.
Gut dann blicken wir doch mal auf die situation in deutschland wie stehen wir denn da pavel.
Ja es tut sich nicht viel was man sagen wir haben der berühmte r ist in der gegend null komma acht fünf null komma neun.
Also auf basis deiner berechnung ne muss heißt nochmal dazu sagen ne.
Aber auf basis auf verschiedener meiner berechnungen also auf basis zweier berechnungen aber es stimmt auch ja weitgehend mit anderen zahlen über ein wenn die halt ausreichend gemittelt.
Man ist war immer noch so dass in berlin wurden dann mal so ein bisschen phantom anstiege auch vermeldet weil da ist scheint immer noch nicht durchgedrungen zu sein dass man in deutschland.
Aufgrund der meldet situation,
keine mehrwerte berechnen kann auf daten weniger als sieben tage man braucht immer mindestens eine volle woche die man vergleichen muss oder sieben tage mit den.
Sieben minus ein tagen oder auch mal davor dass das geht dann aber einfach irgendwie jetzt.
Letzten drei tage oder so zu nehmen ja gute idee erbe rechnung gehen halt der immer vier plus vier tage ein mit dem wert kann man nichts anfangen das führt dann zu anstiegen und abfällen die,
eigentlich nur mit dem wochenrückblick zusammenhängen.
Ja in berlin war es ja dann so jetzt ist aber eins komma drei und dann war er bei null komma drei und.
Mehr anhatte also hin und her und dann ist das das hilft ja auch niemanden solche zahlen zu veröffentlichen.
Das ist auch sagt entbehrt halt auch sogar jeder statistischen grundlage das ist halt.
Dass das noch nicht jetzt inzwischen nach drei monaten noch nicht überall hin durchgedrungen ist sondern dass solche zahlen immer noch in der presse erscheinen und die leute ein bisschen verrückt machen wobei man sagen muss,
in berlin er tatsächlich angestiegen ist es ist tatsächlich nicht.
Unbedingt besser geworden ist dass die zahl der fälle zunimmt so und wirklich ganz einfacher oder.
Weniger umstrittener vergleich als als erbe rechnung ist einfach
indem man sich die letzten sieben tage und die sieben tage davor anguckt und dann die zahlen miteinander vergleicht das,
man auch wenigstens eine etwas größere stichprobe anzuzahlen dann nimmt man das verhältnis und zieht dann die wurzel daraus dann hat man ungefähr auch
ein gutes kompatibles
oder man nimmt halt diesen wöchentlichen wert was dein tabelle als r w immer ausgewiesen ist der sich jetzt bei berlin zum beispiel so bei null komma sieben fünf bewegt
und dann kann man auch einfach in der excel tabelle zum beispiel das ganze fortschreiben und kann dann auch gucken,
wann denn eigentlich jetzt dann schluss ist also wann wird denn wie wenig zahlen haben werden wenn sich das so weiter fortsetzen.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz zur erläuterung für den fall dass wir jetzt noch zuhörer dazu bekommen haben die jetzt noch nicht die letzten drei monate mit uns durch die ganzen zahlen
metin durchmarschiert sind also du hast dir vor einiger zeit mittlerweile mal diese daten geschnappt also die
mehr oder weniger vollständige liste aller gemeldeten fälle in deutschland die veröffentlicht werden vom
wo ist er jeden tag so einen großen datenbank gibt wo wir dann festgestellt haben naja okay man kann jetzt nicht irgendwelche langfristigen schlüsse daraus ziehen wenn man sich nur so ein snapchat eines tages nimmt mittlerweile hast du glaube ich ein archiv von wie weit geht es jetzt zurück du hast ja noch noch ein paar alte daten bekommen ne.
Ja jetzt geht es zurück bis zum sechsundzwanzigsten märz glaube ich heute mal schau mal.
Also auf jeden fall einiges dazugekommen.
Aber leider fehlt sozusagen also es geht los
schon ganz schön auf dem höhepunkt so als uns ganz schön auf dem auf dem höhepunkt befunden haben.
Sollte man mal das anschreiben und darum bitten dass sie nochmal diese daten dampf raus zu wenn sie überhaupt noch.
Ja ja das ist so eine traurige geschichte siebenundzwanzigster dritter ist mein ältester datensatz jetzt aber da war schon am siebenundzwanzigsten dritten war ganz schön was los so wäre halt schön die daten von vorher zu kriegen
aber da ist es so und da ist mir auch fast wieder die hutschnur geplatzt ist arm halt verschiedenste leute so dann.
Anfragen gestellt es gibt da ein paar.
Leute jetzt im open data bereich die sachen konsolidieren also bei den leuten die dann auch ein paar fragen beantworten aber das
selbst sagt nee wir haben zu viel zu tun wir können leider keine bürgeranfragen beantworten nada,
und das muss ich sagen finde ich schon.
Wir machen sich da schon ein ziemlich schlanken fuß als wenn die nicht vielleicht wenigstens eine person hätten die mal ein bisschen
social media monitor und vielleicht auch mal eine schnittstelle zur öffentlichkeit herstellt die nicht nur aus senden besteht.
Sondern vielleicht auch mal bisschen empfangen bisschen reinhören so was ich da tut weil
nicht nur ich sondern es gibt ganz viele auch leute die lesen und schreiben und rechnen können die das gerne alles nachrechnen wollen und die auch ein super job machen in der daten,
aufbereitung so und da wird gar nicht drauf reagiert hat zu getan als gäbe es das irgendwie gar nicht oder weiß nicht scheint irgendwie lästig zu sein das leute irgendwie nachrechnen,
vollen so.
Also das macht mich schon so ein bisschen ärgerlich und wütend und ist etwas was ich für einfach nicht akzeptabel halte sagen wir beantworten keine bürgeranfragen ey was ist denn das wir bezahlten die leute.
Wofür wofür seid ihr denn überhaupt da also ich meine es geht auch darum der öffentlichkeit auch was zu präsentieren aber halt nicht.
Das muss man macht man heutzutage nicht einfach nur uni direkt zu nahe ja das ist da noch so eine alter.
Geiste dann glaube ich meine da gleich die einschränkungen wir wissen ja 'ne menge um die ohren und auch für euch wie du so schön sagt es ist die erste pandemien so.
Jetzt ist er hält auch ein vierteljahr rum so also.
Jetzt ist es genau also dass das hätte ich sage mal für den in der in der hochphase so in den wo sie nicht wussten wohin der kopf stand
würde ich das ja noch als entschuldigung akzeptieren aber mittlerweile so ja.
Finde ich wenn ich mein wenn trosten ich wäre mit seinem podcast könnte man sagen das ganze in die tonne kloppen.
Und gut nicht nur mit seinem podcast sondern auch,
ich sag mal mit seinem tests und seinem seinem wirken aber ansonsten ja haben wir jetzt nicht das gefühl mehr gut da steckt natürlich ein team dahinter das ja nicht alleine und so
aber ansonsten sagen sie performance dort ist jetzt.
Also was die öffentlichkeitsarbeit betrifft.
Was die öffentlichkeitsarbeit angeht und was auch die informationsfluss und veröffentlichung von daten und so angeht,
ist ja sehr spotify würde ich sagen so sehr also ein paar stellen,
okay super aber insgesamt unterm strich
ist es doch mittlerweile jetzt ein bisschen ärmlicher kam ich glaube es gab auch keine antwort die ich jedenfalls keine gesehen auf den appell der daten journalisten den wir hier auch mal hatten so mit den ganzen bitten und konkreten wünschen,
und so auch darf das wurde,
ignoriert und tatsächlich auch die daten die veröffentlicht sind das ist mittlerweile auch klar sind.
So das absolute minimum zu dem sich durchringen konnten und,
die daten sind absichtlich auch so schwer zu interpretieren einmal.
Weil sie beispielsweise eine aussage war ja sie wollen nicht dass jemand aus den daten dann entnehmen kann wenn sich jemand infiziert hat.
Dass diese person dann hinterher auch daran gestorben ist so so solche aussagen kommen dann.
Und ich habe die daten jetzt tatsächlich auch komplett verstanden wie sie.
Numerisch auszuwerten sind und da ist es so man kann,
diese daten nicht konsolidieren dann bekommt man zu bestimmten abweichungen will sagen man kann jetzt nicht aus den ganz vielen daten setzen einmachen weil,
eigentlich steht ja in jedem täglichen datensatz die komplette historie von anfang an mit drin dass man eigentlich denken müsste okay wenn jetzt täglich neue datensätze
kommen dann guckt man was war vorher drin was ist dazugekommen und tut einfach das was dazu gekommen ist dazu und,
macht sagen ein datensatz der dann auch eingangs daten stempel enthält aber,
dass wenn man das macht so kriegt man halt leichte abweichungen und bisher muss ich dazu sagen die große landkreistag bälle macht das auch so
die abweichungen sind nicht groß die man kriegt aber man kriegt halt die sagen offiziellen täglichen meldet zahlen nicht hundertprozentig hin sondern wenn man das machen will muss man tatsächlich die kommt
plätte historie vorhalten und muss dann sämtliche datensätze durchgehen.
So von jedem tag und muss sagen die auswertung für jeden tag mit dem datensatz für den tag getrennt machen und dann all diese auswertung die man dann gemacht hat aufaddieren dann kommt man zu den.
Richtigen zahlen für den richtigen zeitraum wenn man mal eine woche rausgreifen will oder so und ja weil.
Einfach jeden tag irgendwelche datensätze auftauchen oder andere die vorher da waren nicht mehr drin sind in einem neuen daten- und sieht das aber irgendwie angeblich dann doch kompensieren dass die zahlen dann
passen wenn man das halt sagen für jeden tag einzeln rechnet.
Der datensatz ist ja jetzt nicht klein ne also das ist jetzt hundertsechsundachtzig tausend einträge das wächst am laufenden meter an wenn man da jetzt nochmal zurück geht im ende märz waren's ja dann wahrscheinlich auch schon sechsstellig.
Ja
Da muss man millionen an datensetzen durchackern nur um schlüssige informationen bauen zu können aber man kann halt trotzdem daraus nichts zurückbauen also ich finde privatsphäre schutz an der stelle,
bisschen vorgeschobenen argument gut ist jetzt ein bisschen sinnlos groß darauf rumzuhacken aber.
Da holt man sich doch dann einfach mal einen experten rein dessen expertise ist öffentliche daten bereitstellen,
also der sozusagen von der anderen
seite her denkt und lässt ihn da mal so ein bisschen durch die gänge laufen mit allen reden um dann einfach mal einen datenformat zu spezifizieren was einfach auch für alle funktioniert naja.
Nochmal kurz zur also ich hab vorhin eine halbe erläuterung gemacht was was du begonnen hast zu tun und das,
produkt davon ist ja deine landkreis tabelle oder wie sie jetzt offiziell heißt kurvig risiko deutschland nach lindern und kreisen.
Die du jetzt seid wie lange haben wir das jetzt schon vier wochen.
Ja es geht fast schon also ein paar wochen sind es auf jeden fall.
Wird diese veröffentlicht und ist auf deiner webseite zu holen pavel maier de.
Also slash ja die lädt auch immer langsamer muss ich sagen.
Ja ich ich ich hoffe dass zum einen das auch jetzt die tage die neue dash vision
endlich released wird wo dann sagen ein tabellen- back gefixt ist und der das ganze dann deutlich schneller machen wird wobei ich sage das auch dann eventuell auch noch,
also ich werde die tabelle kleiner machen und dann mehr daten sagen dann in den pop up.
Man landkreis anklicken kann und dann.
Komm halt noch mehr detaillierte daten einschließlich dann von sich zeit rein die zurückgehen und wo man.
Dann vielleicht noch in spezifischen tag reingehen kann und sich dann nochmal die fälle des tages oder so angucken kann oder.
Was sagt denn jetzt die tabelle die aktuelle stand achter sechster.
Ich stelle also beim ersten mal draufschauen fest die zahl der von dir wo rot markierten,
und vor allem auch der super rot markierten kreise geht doch spürbar zurück das ist jetzt bestenfalls noch eine bildschirm seite also ich habe dreißig einträge die überhaupt rot markiert sind oder super rot.
Ja wobei super rot nicht,
durchgängig also wir waren auch schon mal auf drei super rote unter jetzt sind's aktuell wieder fünf insgesamt kann man sagen.
Geht's in deutschland runter aber es konzentriert sich halt.
Auf mehr und mehr landkreise so.
Das heißt es gibt definitiv gegenden und kreise wo es immer noch nicht unter kontrolle ist und wo die zahl der infizierten ansteigen,
zwar jetzt nicht auf so einem super hohen niveau aber das ist es leppert sich halt trotzdem das heißt eine kleine gruppe an landkreisen verschlechtert das gesamtbild von deutschland eigentlich während des
in der großen fläche besser wird.
Hallo,
es gibt so ein paar dauerbrenner und es gibt so ein paar die immer mal wieder dazu stoßen jetzt hatten wir ja auch in den medien diese fälle aus göttingen aus den schulen die er dann wieder mal kurzfristigen
schulschließungen geführt haben nachdem sie gerade eröffnet wurden aber so.
Kreise wie coburg sonneberg also coburg bayern sonneberg thüringen es hat mir schon oberfranken da diese diese ecke die.
Kommt irgendwie nicht so richtig zur ruhe und hat immer noch verhältnismäßig viele fälle also göttingen war jetzt krass mit hundertsieben genau bremerhaven ist,
hat sich derzeit problematischer bremen auch noch aber die sind alle so im ja im signifikanten zweistelligen bereich noch.
Und die tauchen halt teilweise immer wieder auf oder sind nicht so richtig ab also irgendwie geht da der virus um und die leute kriegen wenig im griff.
Und ab und zu sprechen auch mal wieder ein berliner bezirk rein was mich auch ein bisschen unruhig macht.
Ja also berlin ist jetzt nicht so die korona erfolgsgeschichte also in berlin nehmen die fälle zu,
also von den vorletzten sieben tagen auf die letzten sieben tage waren es eben immer noch ja waren's zehn prozent,
mehr an fällen von hundert einundachtzig auf zweihundertsechs
und ja das sollte nicht sein so das sollte einfach nicht sein und in spandau ist es offenbar wieder zu ausbrüchen gekommen so ja kreuzberg.
Hat sich auch die zahl verdreifacht so von elf auf dreißig lichtenberg ist geht zwar wieder runter jetzt da.
Gab es ja auch offensichtlich einen ausbruch irgendwo einen begrenzten ich meine man sagen wenn man das verfolgt so.
Gibt es eben tatsächlich landkreise die die springen dann mal nach oben bleiben dann.
Ein zwei wochen relativ weit oben und fallen dann wieder runter dann kann man sagen okay super die haben's irgendwie in den griff gekriegt aber dann gibt's eben andere so,
da merkt man das sind irgendwie dauerbrenner oder die kommen nicht zur ruhe.
Seit wochen nicht so oft gibt es da immer wieder bisschen rauf bisschen runter aber,
auf einem eigentlich noch viel zu hohen niveau und berlin insgesamt wie gesagt dass die fälle hochgehen sollte einfach nicht sein so.
Das ist bedauerlich und.
Ist aber so.
Ja ist aber so ich mein.
Berlin gesamt ist jetzt auch nicht super bedrohlich also in meiner risiko rechnung komme ich jetzt auf einen von tausendvierhundert der möglicherweise infiziert ist oder oder ansteckend ist so,
ja das ist immer noch nicht gut genug um meiner sicht um entspannt.
Wirklichen verkehrsmitteln zu fahren zum beispiel.
Die draußen nimmt glaube ich auch weiter ab so wenn man sich wenn man sich umschaut so
werden die leute doch insgesamt eher unvorsichtiger die abstände werden kleiner und masken wieder teilweise.
Seltener also.
Ja man merkt man merkt richtig wie wie das verdrängt wird so also mental verdrängt wird und so,
ist doch alles vorbei und ja das kann funktionieren aber das
muss nicht unbedingt funktionieren aber es gibt natürlich auch noch eine ganze menge leute die das auch anders sehen man sieht natürlich immer gleich die ausreißer aber so grundsätzlich wird eigentlich schon also was ich schon gemerkt habe ist so,
dieses abstand voneinander halten schon da was er immer so ein paar jungs,
gruppen die fallen dann immer irgendwie auf so aber im wesentlichen geht man sich dann doch so ein bisschen noch aus dem weg und dass das vielleicht auch ganz gut so bevor wir vielleicht auf diese frage mit lockerungen und so weiter und wenn man damit jetzt umgeht,
sollten wir vielleicht nochmal das was wir in der letzten sendung,
so betont haben nochmal genauer nachforschen nämlich die sache mit der hamburg anomalie.
Also wir hatten ja oder du hattest ja dann in deine tabelle eine neue auswertung mit aufgenommen
nämlich dass wir jetzt nicht nur schauen fälle vor vierzehn tagen die woche und die letzten sieben tage und wie verhält sich das zueinander dass er diesen eigenen mehrwert für gebildeten das war so erstmal sehr primäre faktor,
nachdem sich diese ganze tabelle auch sortiert aber dann eben auch paar
andere sachen und dann da man ja eh alles durchlaufen muss und immer sieht wann war denn jetzt eigentlich eine meldung sondern auch felder dazu gekommen mit ok wann war denn überhaupt die letzte meldung wie lange ist das schon her und dann natürlich auch
wenn man sich alle meldungen anschaut wie es denn so die verzögerung weil oft,
wird was sofort gemeldet aber manchmal werden auch ältere fälle später nachgemeldet und es war dann mal ganz interessant das zu sehen und dabei fiel ja auf das ist ein land gab was irgendwie besonders hohe meldet verzögerung hatte das war,
hamburg jetzt hast du.
Der schon vorhin gesagt da wurde mal nachgefragt auf twitter soja hier hamburg wie sieht's denn bei euch aus so ihr meldet irgendwie alles zu spät die so nee.
Alles super bitte weitergehen es gibt nichts zu sehen wir sind hier voll brav und melden alles sofort zack zack kein problem und.
Du hast ja gedacht da schaue ich mir lieber nochmal genauer an.
Also die sache ist die.
Wenn man auf die fallen eingänge drauf schaut so finden wenn du ein neuer fall auftaucht in den daten gibt es einen feld,
so das eben auch sagt neuer fall beziehungsweise neuer fall nur gestern neuer fall nur heute und neuer fall gestern und heute sind so die drei möglichkeiten,
dann gibt es dort eine falle anzahl die dort auch angegeben,
ist für diese ja ich glaube es nennt das ganze fall gruppen also eine falle gruppe ist zu sagen dann.
Eine ist die anzahl der personen die sich am selben tag gemeldet haben das gleiche geschlecht haben und gleich in die gleiche altersgruppe fallen und gegebenenfalls,
das gleiche erkrankungen datum haben oder kein erkrankung datum angegeben das heißt sie werden sagen als eine fall gruppe,
betrachtet und da können dann eben schon mal auch mehr als ein solcher fall da können wir doch schon mal vier zwei drei vier fünf ich glaube das höchste war mal acht was aufgetreten ist überhaupt.
An größe einer einer einer fall gruppe.
Das klingt mir aber auch ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen unwahrscheinlich also acht leute die alle am selben tag erkranken am selben tag melden alle dasselbe geschlecht haben und alle die selbe altersgruppe gehören.
Ja weil es gibt ja nicht so viele altersgruppen so ja ich halte es ja durchaus für für möglich.
Wie findest du denn aufgelöst die altersgruppe.
Es gibt da achtzig plus dann sechzig bis neunundsiebzig dann.
Ja sechzig bis neunundsiebzig fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzig und fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig und also sechs verschiedene altersgruppen glaube.
Okay alles schon grob also so schüler könnte hinhauen aber da müssen natürlich immer noch das geschlecht auch dasselbe sein also naja okay gut aber das ist ja noch alle am selben tag erkranken also.
Gut am selben tag erkranken ja kann auch vorkommen aber überwiegend sind das dann welche die dann kein wo kein erkrankungen datum angegeben ist.
Ja gut aber wenn das später dann doch noch eine erkrankt dann muss es wieder egal also ich verstehe das nicht warum man das überhaupt gruppiert sondern auch einfach jeden fall einzeln machen und fertig macht macht die sache noch einfach.
Der wegen dem datenschutz wegen dem datenschutz genau.
Ja toller datenschutz was ist meine da sind acht datensätze jetzt auch keine andere information als einer also meine steht ja auch nichts anderes drin.
Das sind halt nur separate datensätze also wirklich,
okay aber was ist jetzt mit dieser anomalie hamburg was erlaube hamburg die zahlen sind immer noch groß genug also heute stand ich guck mal rein mittelwert zwanzig komma sieben,
tage melde verzogen also wenn man alle von dir betrachteten meldung und das geht jetzt zurück bis ende april richtig.
Ja
So wenn man sich die anschaut und guckt okay was ist denn wir sind die denn im schnitt wie spät sind die denn dann reingekommen dann sind es halt fast drei wochen,
der median also der aussagt okay was ist denn die es nochmal genau die definition also.
Die hälfte der fälle liegt drunter und die hälfte der fälle liegt drüber.
Genau und das ist allen bundesländern ist es null eins oder zwei also da wird natürlich komme abgeschnitten und so weiter ja also so.
Ne ne da wird.
Nee da gibt's tatsächlich keine keine nachkommastelle sozusagen der ist kein durchschnitt sondern der sagen da muss man sich einen wert aus der tabelle rausgreifen weil es gibt ja keine anderthalb tage melden.
Okay also wenn er steht null dann heißt es ist wirklich die allermeisten fälle noch am selben tag gemeldet werden.
Über die hälfte.
Genau das das sind ja relativ viele bundesländer wir machen das hier schleswig-holstein nordrhein-westfalen hessen thüringen.
Bremen alle null der rest fast durchgehend eins bis auf baden-württemberg brandenburg und das war's dann auch schon die brauchen zwei.
Oder kommt hamburg elf.
So das heißt elf tage dauert es bis bis überhaupt die hälfte der fälle gemeldet haben.
So das.
Hat jetzt aber tatsächlich gibt es dort so einen klaster dring komischerweise das heißt ein,
teil der fälle kommt tatsächlich auch relativ zeitnah wobei sie auch nicht gerade die schnellsten sind also so
meldung am selben tag ist ist wirklich die absolute ausnahme da gibt's andere die sagt das schaffen das schneller also eins zwei oder drei tage ist so kommt halt recht,
häufig vor und dann was all den medialen soweit.
Auch nach oben.
Treibt ist das da in den letzten wochen immer wieder größere mengen an altfällen reingekommen sind,
das sind dann
sechsundzwanzig tage siebenundfünfzig tage neununddreißig tage vierzehn siebenundzwanzig vierundfünfzig achtunddreißig siebenundzwanzig achtunddreißigfünfhundertunddreitausend sage
ja und davon kommt immer mal ein ganzer schwung und gerade so anfang juni kam jetzt auch mal so einen schwung.
Altfälle raus ich lese mal einfach da die jetzt die reihe der der melde verzögerung in tagen einundsechzig fünfundachtzig siebenundsechzig siebenundsechzig sechsundachtzig siebenundsiebzig hundertachtzehn tage.
Siebenundsiebzig dreiundsiebzig und so weiter also.
Ich habe jetzt gerade meine tabelle mal nachgeschaut da sind auch teilweise also das plus fälle und teilweise sind es auch minus fälle also manchmal kommen sie dazu und manchmal kommen sie wieder weg.
Ja die tauchen dann sagen sollten dann eigentlich vorher auch schon mal aufgetaucht,
sein so also die minus fälle ist sagen neuer fallen nur gestern so wenn ich das nicht.
Minus zwei neuer fall nur.
Genau neuer fall nur gestern und das heißt dass dieser fall im,
am vortag schon mal gezählt wurde und irgendwie heute irgendwie nochmal.
Auch nochmal doppelt irgendwo enthalten ist und deswegen halt sagen diese zahl von der heutigen zahl abgezogen werden muss damit man auf den richtigen wert kommt so,
also es ist ja es ist kompliziert so und auch nicht wirklich.
Logisch das heißt aus irgendwelchen gründen.
Tauchen aus hamburg in den daten fälle auf die wirklich,
alt sind also teilweise eben zwei drei monate zurückliegen so wo sich die leute beim also wo sich die leute vor zwei oder drei monaten beim gesundheitsamt gemeldet haben,
und diese fälle tauchen jetzt einfach dort plötzlich auf.
Ich hatte zuerst dann den verdacht kann das vielleicht sein dass es sich da um einfach genießen in meldungen handelt dass man dann vielleicht die gar nicht mitzählen,
darf weil in der regel kommt nämlich bei diesen altfällen dann dieselbe anzahl dann in der regel auch als genießen
raus aber es ist jetzt nicht so dass wenn sozusagen fünf neu fälle und fünfmal genesen in dem datensatz drinsteht
dass man diese fünf fälle jetzt einfach unter den tisch fallen,
lassen kann sondern nein es sind tatsächlich neue fälle die natürlich nach der zeit,
klar in der regel dann auch genießen sind wenn die dann gemeldet werden man muss sie halt mitzählen also wirklich unklar
beim
wo kommen die her es ist nicht nur ich hatte dieses phänomen auch schon bei einzelnen landkreisen hier und da mal gesehen dass plötzlich als als wenn da jemand eine kiste gefunden hätte mit akten und festgestellt hätte ob's die haben ja ganz vergessen irgendwie in den rechner einzugeben und dann hier mach mal und dann,
hat jemand diese fälle nachgetragen sodass wir eine erklärung aber.
Warum das in hamburg seit wochen passiert immer wieder und in nennenswerten umfang das,
ist völlig unklar oder ob hamburg wirklich alles richtig macht und nur irgendwo die software beim robert-koch-institut damit komische dinge veranstaltet
oder die keine ahnung in irgendeiner warteschlange gelandet sind und jetzt abgearbeitet werden vom robert-koch-institut das
können wir mangels transparenz der beteiligten,
nicht sagen fakt ist diese hamburg anomalie ist real.
Die heißt jetzt aber nicht dass die sich aktuell jetzt unbedingt viel zeit lassen sondern es heißt halt dass da irgendwo noch leichen im keller sind
oder irgendwelche fehler beim passieren und dass sie halt diese leichen halt jetzt irgendwie ausbuddeln und ans melden das wäre die erklärung
was natürlich aber dann auch komplett die fallstudie wieder durcheinander,
bringt so an dem tag werden dann eben so und so viel neue fälle gemeldet obwohl die,
tatsächlich für die statistik eher irrelevant sind weil die irgendwann im märz oder april.
Gelaufen sind ja werden aber erst heute als neue fälle gezählt in der täglichen statistik und auch in der bundesweiten statistik ist.
Eigentlich eine ausnahme so ist nicht durchgängig so und warum das ausgerechnet in hamburg so einen einfluss hat ja müssen die hamburger irgendwie was zu sagen oder das was zu sagen.
Schon krass es gibt hier vor allem es gibt hier so fälle hier ist einer gemeldet am ersten juni.
Und es einhundertachtzehn tage her mit anderen worten dann wird ein fall gemeldet der eigentlich ein fall vom dritten februar ist.
Mit dem erkrankungen datum vom siebzehnten januar also so ein richtiger uralt früh fall.
Das ist auch irgendwie absurd so das taucht aber am ersten juni wo lag das.
Was ist das was was erlaube glaube gesundheitsbehörde hamburg also.
Also wie gesagt können kann er in hamburgern liegen kann aber auch irgendwie.
So durchs robert-koch-institut durch deren datenverarbeitung und konsolidierung und was auch immer kommen aber das können wir jetzt nicht sagen,
allerdings spricht er dafür dass es dass es,
was mit hamburg ist weil sonst wenn's jetzt mein artifakt der datenverarbeitung wäre dann würde es andere landkreise auch betreffen oder einem ähnlichen maß betreffen aber das ist schon,
einfach hamburg spezifisch muss man sagen das heißt ich würde deswegen auch mal mit dem finger jetzt doch weiter auf hamburg zeigen was macht ihr da in hamburg,
und wie viel wie viel altfälle können wir jetzt noch erwarten so und wenn die letzten.
Drei tage ist jetzt ein bisschen ruhiger geworden das ist nur ein fall gekommen aber vor vor vier tagen kam nochmal wieder so ein ganzer schwung.
Gut wir werden das weiter beobachten vielleicht normalisiert sich ja hamburg in irgendeiner form nochmal.
Stellt sich jetzt die frage wie sieht es aus mit den ganzen lockerungen also wir haben's ja schon angesprochen so das allgemeine verhalten zumindestens mit unserer berliner aus berlin prenzlauer berg brille.
So naja da draußen üben sich alle schon wieder in so einer normalität die man vielleicht gerne haben will.
Und das kann sich rechnen vielleicht,
sind wir aber auch schon sicher genug ist ein bisschen schwer einzuschätzen und vor allem wird sich das ja frühestens in zwei wochen zeigen jetzt sind auch die lockerung soweit reduziert worden dass jetzt auch kneipen wieder öffnen dürfen.
Restaurants ja schon ein bisschen länger.
Ja das ist so also mit einschränkungen mit zeitlichen einschränkungen et cetera und
relativ wenig leute sitzen drin so ein bisschen meine wahrnehmung aber das jetzt auch echt nur anekdotischen evidence von mir geben kann weil ich da halt selber mich jetzt auch nicht so viel aufhalte es ist mir so das was man so im vorübergehen so
mitbekommt bei restaurants muss man seinen namen aufschreiben auf kontaktlinsen kontakte.
Kontaktlinsen.
Kontaktlisten.
Ja um dann theoretisch sollte dort halt ein fall bekannt werden für das contact tracing bereit zu stehen aber auch das wird nicht überall gemacht so also,
gibt hier so ein burgerladen die machen sich schön einfach da ist dann irgendwie direkt neben der kasse ohne dass man nochmal groß darauf hingewiesen wird liegt da so ein.
Links und r code so mit dem hinweis ja hier kontaktliste bitte einmal scannen und eintragen dann kommt da so eine webseite wo du namen und telefonnummer eintragen sollst.
Natürlich keiner.
Mein eindruck war auch dass ja viele leute natürlich vor allem draußen sitzen das aber draußen oft
einfach zu hundert prozent voll ist und sobald das der fall ist setzt nicht die leute dann auch eher rein
als dann woanders hin zu gehen und da muss ich sagen,
das mache ich bisher noch nicht also ich könnte halt das einfach nicht entspannt genießen so irgendwo drin in einem innenraum zu
setzen derzeit in der kneipe oder in einem restaurant das heißt wenn ich irgendwo weggehe dann nur,
nur draußen.
Oder als innenräume die zumindest gut durchlüftet sind immer es gibt ja auch so kneipen die haben dann halt die möglichkeit große fensterflächen zu öffnen und so ein terrassenfest ling zu stellen also wenn da wirklich das alles sehr luftig ist und die temperaturen erlauben das ja.
Kann man das dann schon fährst du ein bisschen wie draußen sitzen interpretieren wenn man möchte ja nachdem wie engster ist muss dann jeder für sich selber ein bisschen entscheiden denke ich mal.
Worauf ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus wollte ist wie siehst du das.
Mit dem was jetzt sozusagen derzeit noch nicht geht also großveranstaltungen sind nach wie vor untersagt in berlin glaube ich bis ende oktober.
Also so richtig große veranstaltung.
Und was gerade nicht wo so party gerade gezogen werden aber es sind auf jeden fall noch aktiv.
Fünfzig also ich glaube also letzte zahl die ich gelesen hatte war dass du dich jetzt mit bis zu fünfzig leuten
treffen kannst derzeit.
Aber unter beachtung eben von abstandsregelung und ja
gegebenenfalls auch masken empfehlung so aber auf jeden fall die wenn du selbständig mit fünfzig leuten triffst musst du halt gewährleisten dass alle
anderthalb meter voneinander entfernt sind.
Ja das hat ja dieses wochenende super geklappt aber er black label metta demo nicht nur in berlin in vielen städten da waren irgendwie paar tausend leute auf dem alexanderplatz
ich war nicht vor ort von daher kann ich da nichts über abstände sagen aber so das optimum war das sicherlich auch nicht.
Ja also ich ja wenn man halt in im motorradclubs das problem
so dass da natürlich auch das thema monatlich mitgliederversammlung stattfinden die jetzt ausgefallen sind die halt dann neue mitglieder aufnehmen müssen und
ja
und da haben wir werden wir jetzt nächsten monat dann sonne diese woche eine draußen veranstalten so und mit aber mit voranmeldung auch damit irgendwie auch genug platz schaffen können und ich glaube das problem,
betrifft wahrscheinlich schon auch viele andere gruppen und vereinigungen und parteien natürlich gerade so kandidaten aufstellungen und das das ganze das ist natürlich schon noch,
alles einen punkt und.
Wenn man jetzt einfach nur mal davon ausgeht dass sich das so weiterentwickelt deutschlandweit wie bisher dann sozusagen von einer woche zur anderen.
Zahl nur noch drei viertel,
von der vorwoche beträgt dann wären wir in deutschlandweit in drei monaten auf unter hundertneun fälle,
am tag runter also es gibt es nicht gerade super rasant wie das jetzt runtergeht das heißt es geht eigentlich zu langsam,
so und wir werden's ja bis zum herbst wie lange haben wir jetzt dann noch bis zum herbst drei monate
dreieinhalb drei vier monate bis es dann wieder kälter wird und wir dann möglicherweise ja die gefahr der der zweiten welle,
käme,
dann werden wir zu dem zeitpunkt bei entsprechender fortschreibung also nicht linear sondern bei demselben faktor weil wir dann auf sechzig bis achtzig neue fälle mal dunkelziffer quote also man kann sagen.
Wenn das wieder anziehen sollte deutschlandweit durch den durch den herbst so dann sind wir.
Bis zum herbst nicht auf sagen offensichte ihren niveau runter.
Und wie wir wissen so es sich gerade jetzt bei sportveranstaltungen oder großveranstaltungen natürlich kann ein super spray oder kann halt richtig viele leute,
infizieren und ich glaube nicht dass wir diesen sommer soweit,
runterkommen dass man sagen kann jetzt okay die gefahr von super spreding auf großveranstaltungen ist nicht mehr gegeben das wird diesen sommer glaube ich nichts mehr.
Eine voraussagen von dir ist ja auch eingetreten als ja gesagt mitte juni könnte das mit dem urlaub wieder losgehen mit juni sind jetzt ist jetzt angekündigt dass so die grenzberg wieder aufgehoben werden sollen zumindest so weitgehend in europa.
Es teilweise schon passiert also tschechien kann man wieder rein.
Polen ist glaube ich noch bis mitte juni noch beschränkung et cetera ja und dann beginnt natürlich so eine verspätete urlaubssaison.
Die sicherlich dann auch einige dann doch irgendwie wieder ergreifen werden das heißt wir haben dann auch noch wieder interoperabel austausch ich glaube großbritannien dürfte als urlaubsland dies jahr.
Ausfallen.
Hm
Für die meisten spanien muss man nochmal schauen die.
Öffnen ja auch nur langsam ihrerseits ja mal gucken also mir ist das noch nicht so ganz ganz klar wie das so laufen soll und vor allem mache ich mir natürlich gedanken über sowas wie.
Konferenzen messen und fußball.
Was ja auch so ein bisschen im verdacht stand oder auch immer noch steht so mit zu diesem potenziellen supersportler ereignissen zu gehören weil er ja zwei faktoren zusammenkommen.
Eine wirken die einrichtung der andere wirkt in die andere richtung.
Ist draußen von daher erst mal eine andere geschichte aber andererseits kannst dann doch sehr eng zugehen und vor allem wird viel gesungen und also zumindest in manchen stadien.
Wenn manche mannschaften spielen.
Also vielleicht wird auch nicht gesungen sondern es wird nur geschrien aber es ist auf jeden fall stimmt alle mit masken ins stadion.
Also ich bin halt.
Sagt in innenräumen so im öffentlichen raum mich halt mit maske unterwegs und ich finde das gerade jetzt wo die temperaturen auch höher werden so ist es schon verdammt unangenehm finde ich,
mit maske also es nervt ganz schön
so dass man schwitzt dadrunter und und ich glaube auch nicht das finde ich wie wärmer es wird umso unangenehmer wird das halt mit dem masken auch werden aber gut
ja im stadion mit maske wäre schon krass.
Finde ich also ich also ich würde dann würde ich würde das nicht machen.
Wegen der maske.
So aber es gibt bestimmt leute so also in stadion gehen überhaupt wenn ich wenn ich den maske tragen müsste und ohne maske auch nicht so also insofern jeweils nicht diesen sommer.
Die frage nicht ja gut in diesem sommer wird es auch nicht mehr möglich sein es halt eher dann so ab september oktober wahrscheinlich überhaupt das thema.
Mit glück sagt wenn wir unten aber was natürlich unschön ist so dinge wie halt berlin wo die zahlen,
im moment definitiv zunehmen aber dafür habe ich gelesen alle korona ampeln auf grün im moment in berlin.
Gut so wie die konfiguriert sind kein wunder.
Also,
von daher ja man hat mir auch auch beim letzten mal gesagt dass so ja die ampel definition so ein bisschen suboptimal ist in berlin mein besser als sich gar keine regeln zu geben aber die die.
Sich gegeben haben ich glaube auch mit dem mit dem er wert warum die den nicht,
ja immer gesagt alles was über eins ist also wenn es mehr wird ist rot so ist aber in berlin erlauben sie einen höheren erwehrt um.
Ja
weil sie aber was ja einfach gesagt hatten irgendwie untauglichen zahlen verwenden wurde er halt immer rauf und runter hüpft so und dem kann man natürlich begegnen indem man dann ein ein limit von eins komma zwei sätzen was
aber von den schwankungen problemlos übersprungen wird weswegen wir halt dann irgendwelche roten ampel meldungen gesehen haben obwohl über den,
wochenschluss.
Gar nichts war ne.
Hört lange zeit in berlin nix von über eins war.
Vor allem so eine corona ampel die wirklich einen tag lang rot ist und dann ist sie wieder grün nimmt doch keine angst also es ist wirklich unfug unfug und fuck fuck.
Aber man muss sagen eigentlich wenn sich das jetzt noch eine woche so so fortsetzt der trend ist wäre berlin echt auf dem unschönen weg so.
Eine veranstaltung wo wir öfter mal sind ich häufiger du ja nur manchmal ist ja der kongress die stellen sich ja jetzt auch gerade die frage wie es denn oder da stellen sich zumindest alle potenziellen teilnehmer schon seit längerem die frage ob das
das sozusagen eine veranstaltung ist die stattfinden kann und sollte.
Die ist ja so zwischen weihnachten und neujahr das ist ja immer eine sehr virus freundliche zeit eigentlich.
Und genau und die genau und diese veranstaltung ist ja auch immer bekannt dafür krankheitskeime zu verteilen die.
Wobei sich das in den letzten jahren auch deutlich verbessert hat ne also es gab ja mal so eine phase da ist ja immer so ein ganz fensterrand noro virus auf der veranstaltung rumgegangen.
Da hat er dann ein drittel irgendwie die scheißerei.
Und dem ist ja dann mit einem hygienekonzept geantwortet worden ist fast nicht ob sich an diese entwicklung noch erinnern kannst.
Das ist jetzt glaube ich so fünf sechs jahre her das ist mal so ein bisschen schlimmer gewesen ist und dann wurde tatsächlich dann vom medical team auch wirklich so konsequent so händewaschen empfohlen und so weiter was er gerade bei virus dann nochmal besonders.
Hilft und tatsächlich war das so in den letzten jahren immer im rahmen also da gab's jetzt nie irgendwie so ein kolossalen ausbruch.
Aber die die sogenannte kongress krippe und war mehr als ein jahr lang den.
Thema gut was vielleicht auch damit zusammenhängt dass die leute dann wenig geschlafen haben und generell vielleicht ein anfälliger waren.
Ja und sich auch alle auch etwas unter impft sind wahrscheinlich ne also man kann wahrscheinlich jetzt dieses jahr davon ausgehen dass man vielleicht sogar herbst hin dann die aufruf.
Rufe sich doch mal gegen die aktuelle grippe situation impfen zu lassen dann etwas populärer wird.
Weil ich kann mich erinnern dass wir aber auch in der piratenpartei hatten wir dann das phänomen parteitags gruppe also da war auch,
doch häufiger nach seinem parteitagen zu hochzeiten wenn der tausende von leuten zusammen gekommen sind,
lagen dann doch hinterher auch auffallend viele flach es wurden nie wirklich statistiken geführt aber wer.
Man merkt das schon ja auch messe und so weiter also ein großveranstaltung können auf jeden fall ordentlich spray nur ist natürlich jetzt beim.
Virus nochmal ein anderes thema durch die erhöhte medizinische bedrohung an der stelle dass die frage wie geht man mit sowas um und ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so richtig vorstellen dass so das.
Bewusstsein da schon so nachgezogen ist das selbst wenn die fälle niedrig bleiben,
dass man dann unbedingt dem aufruf folgt so und jetzt machen wir eine internationale veranstaltung mit achtzehntausend leuten wo er vier tage lang vierundzwanzig,
stunden am tag zusammen rumhängt.
Und wo auch teilweise gejohlt und geschrien wird in den in den vorträgen oder auch im unterhaltungsprogramm dann.
Es ist.
Schwierig werden.
Ja also ich kann also der punkt ist ja dass man jetzt auch nicht ewig zeit hat die entscheidung zu treffen.
Und so mein gefühl ist eher das ja wenn man wartet.
Das ist klar ist ob.
Die gefahr gebannt ist oder nicht wird es eigentlich zu spät sein um das ding noch durchzuführen weil man kann natürlich jetzt vorher einfach sagen ja gut wir,
wir erwarten jetzt keine zweite welle und wir gehen davon aus dass das bis herbst im griff sein wird was die derzeitigen zahlen für deutschland aber nicht,
wirklich hergeben so wenn man man muss ja sagen es letzte woche haben sich halt immer noch deutschlands zweieinhalbtausend leute,
angesteckt neu,
das ist nicht nichts so das sind verdammt viele ansteckungen finde ich also wenn man es jetzt vergleicht mit,
nichts und wieviel leute müssen jetzt ins land einreisen zum beispiel um die krankheit einzuschleimen oder wie viel müssen im land sein um die krankheit zu verbreiten und bei zweieinhalbtausend ansteckungen waren halt auch sagen
gemessenen ansteckungen so haben sich wahrscheinlich in wirklichkeit eher zwölftausend leute
angesteckt zwölf bis fünfzehn,
werden dann ist bisschen.
Ist nicht schön aber hundert leute werden halt sterben so die sich letzte woche angesteckt haben von von denen also als folge der corona aktivitäten,
ja
ja bis das auf einem bis das offenen level runter ist wo man sagen kann okay das ist jetzt ausgerechnet unsere großveranstaltung treffen sollte,
ist hinreichend unwahrscheinlich das wird so schnell nicht passieren da reden wir halt von,
vier bis sechs monaten kann natürlich sein dass.
Irgendein punkt ist plötzlich sagen man es dann doch irgendwie in den griff kriegt oder andere faktoren noch dazu nimmt und dass wir dann plötzlich doch sauber
sind aber auch die erfahrung aus anderen ländern sprechen eher dagegen wenn man sich china anguckt oder auch
korea da wo es irgendwie einmal sich ordentlich verbreitet hat so scheint es im.
Untergrund oder im hintergrund wie auch immer man das nennt scheint es da doch nach wie vor so eine konstante aktivität zu geben die man nicht sozusagen irgendwelche glutnester die man einfach nicht ausgetreten.
Auch das das thema das ist ja.
Sehr hilfreich wäre für die beurteilung der situation wenn bei den fall meldungen.
Mit veröffentlicht wurde wie viele davon zu einem cluster gehören und wie viele davon jetzt,
völlig unabhängige infektionen sind die man nicht genau zuordnen konnte oder wie ja wie viel cluster man eigentlich hat das wäre so eine so eine wirklich hilfreiche zahl um tatsächlich auch das risiko.
Ein.
Oder halt auch mal alle tests noch mit zu übermitteln also welche personen sind getestet worden und war es positiv oder negativ und das haben wir derzeit nur im positiven.
Dass wir ja angeblich müssten die gesundheitsämtern das eigentlich schon ans melden das heißt es sollte diese zahlen schon haben so ich habe aber noch keine
öffentlichen darüber gesehen so oder keine genauen statistiken bisher da kommt bestimmt was.
Sprichst du jetzt von einer neuankündigung dass das getan werden soll oder das ist schon immer hätte getan werden können.
Es gab vor einigen wochen gab es eine gesetzesänderung die genau sagen das geregelt hat dass die gesundheitsämtern auch negative fälle melden,
soll ja also leute wo die halt,
auf verdacht getestet worden sind und da war es eben bisher so stand war das gesetz so aus gründen des datenschutzes wurden halt nur positive fälle gemeldet und die negativen,
verblieben dann in der obhut des gesundheitsamtes und wurden dann wahrscheinlich sogar auch gelöscht wieder komplett die daten.
Gut uns alle retten soll ja die tolle app.
Und da gibt's vor allem auch nicht so viel zu erzählen heute wird's meine kürzere sendung glaube ich.
Vielleicht so ein paar kleinigkeiten die aber trotzdem nach der erwähnung wert sind also die korona warn-app also die app die hier in deutschland das alles regeln soll
ist nach wie vor für mitte juni angesagt also sechzehnter juni habe ich gehört werden wir sehen ob der tag so genau gehalten werden kann
intern sind wir wohl kurz vor so einer art betatest also.
Wird auch zeit haben heute den achten das sechzehnte ist quasi noch eine woche hin aber ja,
das hat wohl noch nicht stattgefunden oder findet in dieser sekunde wo wir gerade aufnehmen statt keine ahnung irgendwie sowas es sind aber bisher
zumindest schon mal alle code teile veröffentlicht worden also ist jetzt im prinzip alles was dann irgendwann auch releast werden soll ist als source coachen da man kann auch sehen,
bei dem einen projekt mehr bei dem anderen projekt weniger dass eine ganze menge aktivität ist also da wird auch permanent code neu commited und vor allem soweit ich das gesehen habe habe ich zu genau angeschaut aber mein eindruck war
dass da relativ viele leute auch extern beitragen hinweise geben.
Code fixen und das irgendwie übernommen wird das ist für mich jetzt auch ich weiß aber nicht wer jetzt da zum team gehört und wer nicht zum team gehört das natürlich verschiedene player aber es halt einfach eine relativ viel los also auf jeden fall geht die entwicklung,
voran und auf basis,
das veröffentlichen kurz haben sich eben verschiedene leute die mit sich mit backen mit frontend den jeweiligen plattformen auskennen ja war et cetera und entwicklung haben sich das so angeschaut und eigentlich.
Habe ich nichts gefunden wo irgendjemand jetzt mal gesagt hätte das war jetzt aber alles mal ganz furchtbar und ganz schlimm.
Ich glaube so ein paar sachen mit ja hier und die datenbank das hätte man ja auch anders machen können und dann
haben sie ein paar leute da in irgendwelchen länglichen twitter ergeben um dann kurze zeit später darauf hingewiesen zu werden dass dafür schon längst in gibt und das auch irgendwie schon längst bearbeitet worden ist also.
Im großen und ganzen kann man den positiven eindruck der sich bisher ja ergeben hat von dem projekt
weiter bestätigen auch auf heise war eine längere analyse und waren halt immer nur so
ja hier kleinigkeit hier kleinigkeit da und das hätte ich vielleicht anders gemacht aber geht auch so und wesentlichen passt das schon alles also das finde ich ja nach wie vor sehr gut.
Wo ist jetzt natürlich
zweifel gibt es wie weit denn mit dieser digitalisierung der laboren vorangeschritten ist aber jetzt noch nichts konkretes von gehört gab nur so diese munkeln irgendwo gab's einen artikel mit japan
ist ja alles nicht ausreichend digital und wir werden dann sehr viel mit dieser hotline arbeiten müssen.
Also konkret bedeutet das wenn man halt einen test macht kriegt man dann vielleicht entweder noch nicht die idee oder vielleicht funktioniert das auch noch nicht dass der test dann auch wirklich digital zurückgemeldet wird
so oder so wird es aber eine hotline geben wie gut die funktioniert das werden wir dann sehen also das,
kann man ja vorher noch nicht sagen kann sein dass dann auch wieder irgendwelche callcenter katastrophen gibt aber da ist meines wissens auch die telekom so ein bisschen dran mit telefon und so weiter sollten sich ja eigentlich auskennen.
Dann ist natürlich die frage wie gut sind die mitarbeiter geschult und und und und und kriegen sie auch genau die anfragen und die art und weise von problemen für die sie dann geschult wurden.
Kann man derzeit einfach alles noch nicht sagen kann sein kann nicht sein und klar wenn er mal eine woche irgendwie oder zwei
alles noch etwas durcheinander gerät würde ich jetzt auch noch nicht gleich die bahn glocken läuten lassen größere frage ist natürlich eher.
Wird es denn überhaupt so funktionieren wie man sich das gedacht hat insbesondere was du die installation zahlen betrifft.
Und gut da gibt's ja jetzt im prinzip zwei lager die einen lager sagen.
Ja hier datenschutz paar neuer desinteresse etcetera zentriert sich doch keiner oder zumindest keine nennenswerte zahl.
Und dann wieder die sechzig prozent werden wir nie erreichen und dann ist das ja sinnlos.
Woher nicht so mitgehen würde also klar umso mehr das installiert umso höher die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es auch was bringt aber das heißt aber lange nicht dass es nichts bringt wenn's weniger installieren ja man kann immer noch fragen ja okay sind denn das dann genug,
um vor allem erfolg zu sprechen aber ich stehe hier so auf dem standpunkt das man sagt na ja also jeder klasse der früher in griff bekommen,
werden kann ist den aufwand schon mal wert ohne jetzt irgendwelche zahlen zu kennen was da jetzt an geld rausgeworfen wurde oder so aber das ist halt,
meine entwicklung dann wird man jetzt mal geld drauf dass es sicherlich im im,
gesamtrang der finanziellen anstrengungen die deutschland gerade unternimmt um dieses ganze
debakel irgendwie in griff zu bekommen absolut sekundär war wahrscheinlich nicht mal die richtige bezeichnung sondern das so unter ferner liefen was die gesamte investition betrifft.
Ja dann stellt sie einfach die frage wie wie wird das dann lauf mit dem marketing also wie.
Wie kriegt man die leute dazu dann ist hier auch mit ins boot zu springen.
Tja also aus meiner sicht also ich werde mir das ding installieren erstmal
salopp gesagt und ich bin ja eigentlich kein freund von so argumentationen wie ja und wenn dadurch nur ein menschenleben gerettet wird dann war's das schon alles wert sondern tatsächlich
muss halt real bleiben so natürlich kann man jetzt in einen menschenleben nicht ohne weiteres mit geld aufwiegen,
auf der anderen seite.
Muss man es in der politik irgendwo ständig tun so also man da kann man zwar jetzt nicht individuell jetzt einen wert beimessen aber
muss natürlich sollte natürlich schon auch das geld was immer begrenzt ist natürlich dort einsetzen möglichst wo es den meisten nutzen entfaltet.
Jetzt im fall von corona app würde ich aber tatsächlich sagen und wenn dadurch ein menschenleben gerettet wird war es das wert weil erstens war,
das bisher nicht so teuer ist jetzt kein milliardenprojekt sondern das ist im
vergleich zu den anderen corona kosten kosten wahrscheinlich diese app nicht mehr als die tests die an einem tag gemacht werden,
größenordnungsmäßigen also ist jetzt lang von den kosten hier kein thema und vom datenschutz würde ich einfach mal sagen also jeder der.
Entweder auf facebook ist oder google als,
suchmaschine benutzt ohne dazwischen geschalteten anonymisieren oder.
Seine oder einen.
Webseiten rumsurfen ohne.
Genau oder sagen die lokalisierung funktion von seinem telefon benutzt also sozusagen eine maps anwendung so,
all diese sachen die ich jetzt aufgezählt habe sind halte ich für.
Um größenordnungen bedenklicher was den datenschutz
angeht wenn ich nicht möchte dass irgendjemand weiß wo ich mich aufgehalten habe dann darf ich eigentlich kein mobiltelefon mit mir rumtragen
oder kein facebook nutzen oder unterwegs kein internet nutzen und ja
nicht nicht telefonieren möglichst familie vermeiden dass man angerufen wird so all all diese dinge hinterlassen einfach deutlich mehr datenspuren.
Als er als die corona warn-app beziehungsweise das exposé tracking ja also ich.
Da wirklich wenig bedenken im moment die app zu installieren so weil.
Also schaden kann es nicht und ja es kann eigentlich nur helfen.
Selbst wenn's nur wenig hilft finde ich ist es auch okay und es ist das wert was jetzt die frage nach dem marketing,
angeht was kann man da tun das
mehr leute das benutzen ich fürchte man kann's eigentlich fast nur verkacken so am besten wie ich irgendwie gar nichts tun und sagen hier nur bekannt machen,
hier das ist die warn-app so.
Ich würde jetzt keine plakataktion oder fernsehspots oder weiß ich nicht gut kanzlerin könnte es noch erwähnen vielleicht das jetzt die korona warn-app da ist aber,
ja ansonsten sollen die leute doch machen was sie für richtig,
halten also mir geht's jedenfalls so wenn ich dann irgendwo sehe so da wird jetzt werbung da wird jetzt geld ausgegeben um mich zu manipulieren oder zu beeinflussen weil,
information ist es ja so gut wie nie jetzt werbung so also der informationspunkt spielt da ja
keine rolle und wenn ich das gefühl habe da gibt jemand geld dafür aus
um sozusagen für meine gehirnwäsche und vielleicht zahle ich dann sogar noch um höheren produktpreis dafür dass ich gehirn gewaschen worden bin durch werbung deswegen reagiere ich auf sowas eher allergisch es kann mich eigentlich nur abschrecken und
ich weiß nicht wie es in anderen leuten so geht aber ich denke,
das wird niemanden entgehen dass es diese corona gibt und ja.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher dass das niemanden entgeht also das.
Ich glaube schon das wird vielen entgehen also was ich okay dann deine these ist bloß nicht zu viel darauf hinweisen weil das ja zu so einer gegenreaktion führen könnte.
Genau also wenn man sagen wenn wenn jetzt die regierung irgendwie ganz bemüht tut irgendwie ihr müsst jetzt diese app installieren glaube ich ist es eher kontraproduktiv.
Weiß ich nicht so ganz genau ich meine jetzt haben wir das habe ich ja schon kurz angesprochen jetzt haben wir ja im prinzip diese geschichte mit den kontaktlisten.
Du musst dich eigentlich wenn wenn der restaurantbesitzer das richtig macht et cetera so und hast du ja auch vor einiger zeit schon mal angesprochen so da musst du dann halt name.
Telefonnummer weiß ich glaube name telefonnummer frank email.
Nummer und oder e-mail adresse ich glaube eins von beiden also individuell.
Wo man halt irgendwie
kontaktiert werden kann musst du alter irgendwie reinschreiben gut ob die leute das das richtige da reinschreiben ist nochmal eine andere frage ne also kannst du natürlich auch irgendwas reinschreiben okay
was machen die leute damit müssen halt zwei wochen um diese zettel im schrank halten und danach wegwerfen natürlich kann man auch wunderbar könnte man da wunderbar dann irgendwie ein whatsapp verteiler draus bauen aber ich glaube dass
würde glaube ich nicht so gut kommen wenn irgendein restaurant das tatsächlich machen würde aber so in puncto datenschutz wenn man mal diese perspektive nimmt,
es ist halt absolut in kombiniert ich dachte mir halt sowas.
Derzeit muss ja sowieso alle restaurants in alle läden entsprechende hinweise vorhalten mit hier nur mundschutz das das das ja dass man dann halt ein allgemeinen.
Die bundesregierung informiert zettel designt ja den einfach alle läden vorne anzubringen haben.
Der halt auf was auch immer gerade die aktuelle sicherheitslage empfiehlt ja so mundschutz ja oder nein.
Und dabei auch darauf hinweist dass diese app gibt ohne jetzt mit mit hüpfenden glücklichen menschen,
ja wir versuchen irgendein ein ein unsinn da vor zu zelebrieren aber einfach dadurch so konstant so ein q code da in die welt zu setzen und sagen so hier scannen zack bumm kannst mithelfen.
Und diesen mithelfen charakter zu betonen und dieses positiv versprechen mit das könnte dazu führen dass wir auf sowas wie kontaktlisten verzichten können.
Das das wäre vielleicht eine maßnahme die man machen könnte tatsächlich also es ich gehe davon aus dass wenn die da ist wird es in jeder.
Zeitung in jedem outlet wird es ein hinweis darauf gibt und ich würde mich nicht wundern sogar wenn es im prinzip auf jeder titelseite.
An einem tag.
An einem tag genau.
Aber nur an diesem einen tag.
Genau und da wäre es auch tatsächlich.
Dann vielleicht hilfreich wie du gesagt hattest wenn zum beispiel dann auch die zeitungen oder webseiten sogar auch.
R code mit einem link auf die jeweiligen shops oder auf eine jump seite,
veröffentlichen wo dann nochmal erläutert ist vielleicht was was das ding macht und
was man da da tut das wäre vielleicht eine gute sache und was so gesagt hast sagen aushänge in shops wer sich glaube ich auch nichts gegen
einzuwenden wenn wenn das passiert so das wäre wahrscheinlich auch nicht verkehrt aber.
Sagt ich kann's mir tatsächlich nicht nicht vorstellen dass ja dass es viele leute gibt die einen aktuelles mobiltelefon haben die.
Und das nicht mitkriegen werden dass es diese app gibt.
Es gibt leute die haben einen aktuelles mobiltelefon und die hat noch nicht mal mitbekommen dass man überhaupt installieren kann.
Ja aber wie viel prozent sind das also.
So wie ich aus podcast raushöre
beunruhigend viele also man man da haben wir glaube ich so ein bisschen das problem,
dass dass wir sowas schnell überschätzen können ja und ich will jetzt auch nicht hier vorstoßen und sagen voll gut so,
dreißig millionen installationen in vier wochen das wird nicht stattfinden ich rechne damit dass ding wird rauskommen.
Dann werden so die die nerds und die aufgeweckten und die die sich schon lange mit dem thema beschäftigen werden dinge ne million mal runterladen innerhalb der ersten woche weil einfach interesse interesse interesse so ja dann wird es eine weile abgeben.
Und dann wirst du ja so ein kontinuierlichen langsamen steigerungsraten sehen.
Der vor allem dadurch geschwächt wird das jetzt sommerferien anfangen die leute andere sorgen haben und generell auch diese wahrnehmung der bedrohung derzeit einfach gering ist,
das ist ja das hat mir jetzt hier schon fünfmal so gefühlt ist corona vorbei,
nicht unbedingt weil die zahlen da jetzt eine deutliche sprache sprechen sondern weil einfach so eine normalisierung herbeigesehnt wird.
Hermann man will das auch.
Man man will dass es irgendwie weg ist weil es jetzt zu lange da war und wir irgendwie wieder diese freiheit spüren und die sonne scheint und man will sich irgendwie auf dem campingplatz setzen und und über andere sachen nachdenken und gegen herbst werden wir dann aber sehen.
Okay das dann verschiedene faktoren da wieder mit reinkommen was weiß ich
höhere bedrohungssituation weil ausbrüche in manchen ländern oder vielleicht auch in deutschland an verschiedenen stellen und auf einmal wird das thema wieder da herbst an sich als bedrohung die leute wissen dass sie sich jetzt wieder enger zusammen kuscheln müssen und vor allem,
weil sich dann zu dem zeitpunkt vielleicht dann eben auch dieses ganze subsystemen was er überhaupt es sich erstmal beweisen musste labor test und so weiter,
dann auch seine ersten kinderkrankheiten ausgeschwitzt hat denkt immer das wird so sicherlich vier bis sechs wochen dauern bis du also die.
Größten probleme,
auch dauerhaft behoben sind dass man sagen kann okay das funktioniert jetzt auch jetzt auch schon ein paar mal getestet und es hat vielleicht auch schon der ein oder andere erfolg gezeitigt so also es wird also eine news meldung sein so erste person.
Positiv getestet die von ihrem telefon zu einem test aufgerufen wurden das ist so die botschaft ist erstmal brauchst und es wird wahrscheinlich noch eine weile dauern
also das ding wird einfach vier bis sechs wochen lang in der versenkung in der mentalen versenkung verschwinden und dann
durch irgendwelche sekundär ereignisse entweder durch gestiegene bedrohungslage oder eben durch positive ergebnisse in deutschland oder sonst irgendwo ins bewusstsein zurückgespielt werden und dann wird's eigentlich erstmal entscheidend sein wie
dann die installation zahlen zunehmen.
Ja
Max auch noch was zu sagen.
Wenn wir schon irgendwie bei zukunft vorhersagen sind also ich,
denke auch es wird wird erstmal auf jeden fall einen ziemlichen installationen geben so der mehrere tage andauern wird durch auch dazu führt dass die,
dann in den stores weil sie so viel ins selbst wenn,
wenn sie jetzt nicht künstlich nach oben pushen würde würde sie dann halt in den top ten wahrscheinlich vermutlich wird die auf platz eins landen das heißt wann immer du den play store.
Oder den app store aufmachst und in die top ten guckst wird sich dort die chorona warn-app erstmal für eine weile befinden so dass alleine treibt natürlich dann schon mal die die downloads nach oben
aber ja.
Dass sich das möglicherweise in mehreren wellen vollziehen könnte denke ich auch also jedes jedes mal wenn das ding irgendwie in die presse kommt dass es irgendwie was positives gebracht hat wird's wahrscheinlich jedes mal einen kleinen schub,
geben und ja aber ich ich hoffe doch oder ich erwarte eigentlich dass wir doch,
relativ schnell die zwanzig oder dreißig prozent erreichen werden und jetzt mal die frage worauf bezieht sich das auf die.
Zahl der auch schon auf die zahl der handys auf die zahl der der handys die technisch dazu in der lage sind,
aber tatsächlich mehr festgestellt es gibt verdammt viele handys in in deutschland ich glaube sogar mehr mobilfunk
verträge als einwohner beziehungsweise offiziell ist der durchdringung grad wie viele personen in handy befinden deutlich über neunzig prozent und.
Insofern,
einmal bevölkerung wahrscheinlich könnten wir schon die vierzig fünfzig prozent irgendwann erreichen hoffe ich dass die dann mit so einer corona warn-app
rumlaufen und das wäre dann schon mal ziemlich nützlich wenn wir da hinkommen ich glaube selbst bei selbst fünfundzwanzig prozent werden schon
ganz schön aber fünfzig prozent werden halt ja mindestens fünfundzwanzig mal besser als zehn prozent.
Es gab auch releases in anderen ländern jetzt bin ich mir nicht ganz so sicher was ich letztes mal schon berichtet hatte also es gibt definitiv die estnische.
Tobi in italien ist auch die app die also sowohl die erste scheiße aus italienische basiert auch auf diesem google apple standard italien heißt sie immun.
Die kann man auch beide hier in deutschland installieren.
Da gibt's keine beschränkung die sind einfach in den app store international reingedrückt worden die österreichische.
App auf basis derselben technologies stopp corona ist nur im,
österreichischen app store herunterladbaren habe ich den eindruck also ich kann sie zumindest in deutschland nicht runterladen ja gut vielleicht kann man machen.
Weiß nicht ob da jetzt unbedingt irgendwas,
zielt mit verhindert werden soll oder ob man leuten da nicht im zweifelsfall nur schwer war schwerer macht gut am ende wird es alles auf dieses roaming ankommen was wir hier schon mehrfach diskutiert haben wo es aber
diese woche überhaupt nichts neues zu berichten gibt also diese apps kommen.
Frankreich hat seine zentrale also mit dem rest in kompatiblen app veröffentlicht.
Auch da wird man jetzt absehen müssen wieder die adoption ist und wieder die erfahrung damit sind ich befürchte schlimmeres.
Ja und dann wird deutschland und schweiz wenn er jetzt sich noch dazu gesehen damit hätten wir dann zumindest schon mal so einen.
Ja ist so schön dach verbund der auf demselben standard basiert plus italien,
und das wäre dann schon mal was um erste erfahrungen auch zu sammeln gerade im hinblick darauf dass das auch so länder sind die sich wahrscheinlich demnächst auch mehr besuchen werden.
Also urlaub wird deutschland wahrscheinlich im wesentlichen in deutschland stattfinden aber eben auch ein bisschen in österreich und ja also was ja so tschechien irgendwas gehört.
Nix aber.
Ich gucke halt gerade tatsächlich im produktiv betrieb ist noch keine der apps bisher oder also.
Doch die italienische und die technische.
Okay die sind.
Also wir sind zumindest releast worden.
Die schweiz interessanterweise noch nicht.
Die schweizer ist noch in der phase ich vermute mal dass die zeitgleich mit der deutschen rauskommen wird aber es ist eine reine vermutung habe ich gar keine informationen aber es wüsste nicht so richtig was da jetzt in der schweiz sehr viel länger dauern sollte als in deutschland.
Italien also die haben auch schon richtig scharf geschaltet ach so ja also.
Scharf geschaltet im sinne von du kannst die app installieren und sie fängt an kurz auszusenden.
Ob ich jetzt in italien einen test machen kann und die app auch wirklich in der lage ist den hochzuladen kann ich dir nicht sagen ja weil das so müsste ich habe ich habe ich keinerlei informationen.
Können wir mal vielleicht dann bis nächste woche dann nochmal genauer uns vielleicht die mal anschauen zu versuchen zu installieren hast du versucht irgendwas davon zu installieren jetzt.
Ja also ich habe diese estnische habe ich installiert und das lässt sich alles installieren und dann ist es irgendwie an so.
Welche app das macht es ja egal es kann bloß immer nur gleichzeitig also der zumindest was jetzt nicht genau wie das andere aussieht aber der kann immer nur eine app die aktive app sein.
Und das bedeutet dass es sozusagen die app die kies einspielen kann also die vom netz.
Kies empfangen kann und die überprüfen kann das darf immer nur eine.
Vermutlich um da konfusion zu verhindern viele leute haben.
Und ich habe das auch schon gehabt so eine meldung bekommen ja hier dein kontakt ding sie ist in deiner region nicht verfügbar und so.
Das ist ein bisschen seltener geworden in den letzten tagen ich vermute dass da irgendwo noch ein back schlummerte oder irgendein backend ein bisschen frei gedreht hat
weil was das wahrscheinlich das habe ich nicht so hundertprozentig bestätigen können aber was das wahrscheinlich sagt es so
dass du so eine meldung bekommst wenn du in ein land gehst wo quasi keine kompatiblen app ist und,
wie gesagt nur so so eine so eine vermutung ja dass wenn du irgendwo hinreist und dann so ja hier ist sozusagen offiziell gibt's keine offizielle app die unser protokoll verwendet hier kannst du mit niemandem kontakt.
Daten austauschen.
Was ja für deutschland im moment sinn machen würde.
Weil weil es hier halt eine offiziell noch gar keine gibt so nur ist das halt mal wieder so eine mitteilung die einem irgendwie.
Ein bisschen merkwürdig vorkam und komischerweise konnte man dann durch den trick einmal wlan ausschaltet und wieder einschalten kam es dann gleich wieder hoch mit eier wieder läuft wieder alles also.
Deswegen vermute ich da halt eher so ein back aber diese meldung ist offensichtlich für so etwas gedacht
aber ich habe so den eindruck dass sie da noch am feintuning sind wie sie dieses ganze warnsystem im hintergrund scharf schalten sollen.
Also ich denke mal nächste woche bis man da mehr und im laufe dieses monats.
Können wir dann auch langsamer erkenntnisse darüber gewinnen wie populär oder unpopulär dieser vorstoß denn letzten endes wirklich ist ob's ob in die eine oder in die andere richtung da überrascht werden und.
Dann macht's auch sinn auch erst nochmal monat später zu schauen okay sind denn jetzt hier schon irgendwelche warnungen rausgegangen hat tatsächlich kontakte gegeben etcetera da brauchen wir dann halt wieder solche vorfälle.
Hier kirchen.
Clubs kneipen was auch immer die wird sicherlich dann wieder geben und dann muss ich halt einfach zeigen ob leute tatsächlich ein telefon dabei hatten schulen außenthema jetzt dürfen alle kids auch ihre telefone mit in die schule nehmen.
Auch mal ein faktor ich kann mein telefon nicht ausschalten ich muss ja gott tschüssing machen.
Ich meine wie wichtig dass jetzt auch ist dass
diese warn-app so datensparsamkeit ist und so zugenagelt ist kam natürlich jetzt am beispiel usa leider muss man muss man sagen
bestätigt sich das weil weiß nicht ob du das,
gelesen hat es aber das wohl irgendwo in mindestens einem staat wo es auch eine korona warn-app,
gab so eine dressing
app die aber eben nicht auf diesem standard beruht sondern wo die nicht vor ein paar monaten oder ein paar wochen vorgeprescht sind und einfach irgendwas gemacht haben dass diese daten
jetzt sankt zur aufstandsbekämpfung eingesetzt werden sollten.
Wenn du da einen artikel gefunden hast zu dem thema wo explizit von einer app die rede ist,
nämlich das thema gerne nochmal auf aber das der einzige der herumgereicht wurde da war immer nur so ominöse von tools die rede.
Es wurde in keinem zusammenhang konkret von einer app gesprochen ich glaube das ist so ein bisschen so eine fehlwahrnehmung gewesen.
Trotzdem ist natürlich so dieses,
oh ja wir benutzen jetzt mal die daten aus dem aus dem contact tracing um irgendwie rauszukriegen wer hier mit wem und so weiter
ist natürlich auch schon eine harte ansage weil es ja im prinzip gegen die
privatsphäre verstößt die ja eigentlich auch so eine gesundheitsebene gesichert sein sollte nur dass es halt die usa und nicht deutschland deswegen habe ich überhaupt gar keine ahnung welche standards tieren und das ist natürlich auch eine kampfansage,
aber gut das spricht trotzdem.
Du sprich trotzdem natürlich für dein argument gut dass man eine architektur gewählt hat wo das so erstmal gar nicht geht.
Und das das ist ja sozusagen gesichert hat mir hier mehrfach diskutiert es einfach bei design verzichtet man einfach auf 'ne,
auf dem theoretischen erkenntnis gewinnen der so auch von niemandem bisher hat belegt werden können aber wir schließen damit eben,
aus dass eine überprüfung von außen von kontakten irgendwo in einer folge der man vertrauen muss stattfinden kann und das ist dass es halt gut ne weil dadurch kann man dann halt eben sagen okay ja nee könnt ihr könnte installieren.
Ist jetzt erstmal kein problem die installiert zu haben so einfach.
Derzeit keinen angriffsmodus auf diesen daten austausch der in irgendeiner form eine nennenswerte informationen,
über einen selbst oder über einen selbst im verbund mit anderen generiert und und das macht es natürlich sehr viel einfacher
diese diskussion dann auch zu führen in der öffentlichkeit die das team hat ja auch sich konkret zu diesem.
Technischen anforderungen die der c veröffentlicht hatte vor ein paar wochen geäußert also es war so eine liste von zehn dinge die so generell.
Erfüllt sein sollten davon waren glaube ich vier oder fünf technischer natur und dazu haben sie sich dann eben auch konkret geäußert und dargelegt warum ihrer meinung nach diese app und dieser gewählte architektur diese anforderungen erfüllt.
Was sie meiner meinung nach auch tut.
Also nochmal ich hatte nochmal jetzt geguckt so wo ich das eigentlich härte und so ist tatsächlich
so dass nichts konkretes wirklich da ist das nur sagen angeblich in minnesota die polizei gesagt hat sie würden jetzt die demonstranten kontext tracer.
Und das kann tatsächlich sein also es gab,
eine reihe von auf jeden fall auch dass keine neue technologie ge plant ist oder im einsatz sei oder was auch immer und dass sie irgendwie sich nur dieses wort geliehen haben
und es könnte halt sein dass wie vieles was darf gerade von amtsträgern in den usa so zum besten gegeben wird dass es tatsächlich
bullshit sein könnte ja.
Aber hätten wir eine andere architektur ja die von vornherein sagt so hier gib mal schön deinen namen ein und,
schick mal deine kies die du so rum gesendet hast und dann landen die beide in der wolke wobei auch das,
vorgeschlagene zentrale modell in deutschland hätte das so nicht ohne weiteres hergegeben sondern auch immer nur im falle einer positiv meldung aber es gibt ja andere länder die gehen da ja ganz anders ran.
Also in brasilien gibt's irgendwie so wo dir dann sogar die location von infizierten leuten,
auf der matte gezeigt wird und so eine nummer also so richtig hardcore ja na klar das sind natürlich datenbestände da kann man richtig schön rein tanken aber,
gar nicht mal nur in solchen demonstrationen sondern generell um das wäre mit wem herauszufinden deswegen ist es halt
natürlich hochproblematisch aber das zeigt eben dass es sinnvoll ist von vornherein einfach da maximal privatsphäre schon dran zu gehen um da am ende eben auch mit konferenz sagen zu können so jani könnt ihr schon benutzen passt schon.
Und man sieht eben dass alleine das wurde dann auch kritisiert dass alleine nur die erwähnung
die verwendung des wortes contact tracing in dem zusammenhang schon verdammt viel schaden verursacht hat.
Weil die leute dann halt sagen so ja die app installiere ich nicht oder ich ich lasse mich gar nicht testen und so.
Genau und das ist natürlich dann her das ist dann schon echtes problem wenn sie sagen einfach nur in einem falschen zusammenhang,
dieselbe terminologie benutzt wird und das dann als pressemeldung um die welt geht.
Also gefährlich auf jeden fall ansonsten bin ich noch ich weiß nicht ob du das hättest dass die in die polizei für sich eine eigene contact tracing app
in auftrag gegeben hat und benutzen möchte.
Nein das habe ich noch nicht gehört für sich selber wieso denn das.
Ja ja planning der contract tracing system konzerns wort government version.
Oh mann also in großbritannien ist es natürlich wie mit allem gerade ein totales chaos
also die haben natürlich von vornherein gesagt so ja nee hier google apple ihr könnt uns mal wir machen hier unser eigenes ding wir wollen hier maximal überwachungsstaat mal wieder
machen dann haben sie irgendwie so eine so eine so eine erste app daraus gebracht dann haben sie die irgendwie auf einer insel auf dieser of white haben sie die irgendwie getestet
das war wohl auch schon so eine mittlere katastrophe.
Nicht so richtig funktioniert und viel zu wenig leute haben da überhaupt mitgemacht et cetera jetzt stehen sie natürlich wieder mit leeren händen da das ganze im konzert mit der mit dem generell desaströsen zustand der ganzen
des ganzen managements der der pandemien in also das als ich
das hat nochmal wirklich das potential so richtig als mega fehl in die geschichte einzugehen ähnlich wie in den usa passieren natürlich auch.
Ja
Bei den apps haben sie auch nichts auf die reihe.
Ja ich weiß was dahinter steckt bei der polizei warum die ihre eigene app haben wollen aus angst um ihre andere cover leute.
Genau nicht die staatsapparates raten wir ja alles das sagt eine menge aus das sagt eine menge.
Es ist natürlich eine echt vertrauensbildende maßnahme wenn die polizei sagt irgendwie ne also also das offizielle system nee nee das ist für unsere also für unsere polizei ist das nicht
tabea das ist.
Großartig.
Das ist wirklich also es wird wenn man das wenn man da drehbuch schreiben müsste irgendwie es wird einem keiner abnehmen.
Ja das kommt davon wenn man sich so eine so eine bekloppten regierung zusammen wählt naja naja gut.
Ja gut ja also mir fällt jetzt.
Ja mir auch nicht ich glaube das war's.
Jetzt auch erstmal nichts mehr ein.
Etwas kürzere sendung du bastelst mal weiter an deiner tabelle.
Na ja ja.
Und
mal gucken was da schönes bei rauskommt ich werde weiterhin diesen markt da im auge halten und dann würde ich meinen wenn die app dann draußen ist dann.
Sollten wir uns die hier nochmal in ruhe anschauen.
Ja
Also könnt ihr in der woche funktionieren ungefähr dann sind wir noch dann sind wir noch so halbwegs weekly noch noch gibt's gerade noch genug her so aber irgendwann.
So so genau.
Irgendwann gibt's nochmal pause.
Aber es wird tatsächlich es ist entspannt sich außer eben ja.
In berlin.
In berlin und in ein paar anderen ecken des landes wo es nicht zur ruhe kommt und.
Vielleicht lohnt es dann auch mal nochmal den blick international auszubreiten brasilien.
Überhaupt zu damen sieht überhaupt nicht schön aus und auch in schweden gab's glaube ich gerade wieder ein.
Krassen ausbruch also da ist auf jeden fall noch unterhaltung.
Vielleicht auch zusammenfassen irgendwie es wird besser aber ihr seid nicht sicher.
Genau damit schicken wir euch jetzt mit diesem beruhigenden worten schicken wir euch jetzt in die woche okay danke pavel tschüss.
Tschüss.
Tschüss an alle die zugehört haben nächste woche.